in the 1950s scientists believed high
banked rivers throughout the eastern
united states
a signature of the landscape resulted
from repeated floods which piled
sediment onto the sides of rivers
decades later researchers dorothy merits
and robert walter
presented a different theory for how
these steep banks came to be
human activity in 2008 they published a
paper in science
suggesting that when europeans arrived
in the u.s 500 years ago
rivers on the east coast were marshier
and had far lower banks
to this day their findings call into
question the best way to spend the
millions of dollars funneled towards
improving rivers every year
merits and walter's study began in the
little conestoga creek
when a student showed merits a photo of
six meter high walls of sediment
merits doubted that floodwaters could
have deposited enough silt to make a
bank that
tall her colleague robert walter agreed
and suggested that they might have
formed from still not moving water
it didn't take long for them to find the
cause of the standing water
a dam downstream from the site these
mill dams were used to power flower
and textile mills after digging through
historical maps and conducting field
work
they found mildams were abundant
throughout pennsylvania
further research also showed they
cropped up in other parts of the eastern
united states
merit and walter concluded the thick
banks were made up of legacy sediment
soil that eroded from the intense land
transformation of colonial era logging
and
farming they were concerned that these
large packages of sediment
still laden with pollutants could
negatively impact water quality as it
eroded into the river channel
when too many nutrients like phosphorus
and nitrogen end up in waterways
it can upset the delicate balance of
ecosystems by causing
massive algal blooms that gobble up
oxygen
they believed restoration efforts that
didn't address legacy sediment
could run into problems with pollution
down the road
not all researchers agreed with their
conclusions
some pointed to areas without dams with
lots of legacy sediment
while others argued that the old 1950s
framework still stood true
amidst all the debate state and federal
agencies
weren't sure how to account for legacy
sediment in future projects
the duo decided to apply their findings
on a smaller scale
a tributary of the little conestoga
creek which borders the sprawling farm
fields of lancaster pennsylvania
in 2011 over 22 thousand tons of legacy
sediment were removed from the banks of
big spring run
transforming the steep meandering river
to a braided
gently sloping system today
big spring run is almost unrecognizable
wetlands have emerged and native species
of animals and plants flourish
the wetlands soak in flood waters while
the vegetation helps hold sediment
in place preventing large amounts from
moving down river
a report published this year shows just
how effective this rehabilitation was
85 percent less sediment and 79
less phosphorus make their way
downstream
removing thousands of tons of sediment
is costly up front
about 1 150 per one meter of stream
length
but it's far more effective at reducing
sediment and nutrient pollution than
other
more well-known management practices
like planting vegetation on the banks of
rivers to filter sediment before it
enters the water
its success has spurred similar projects
and more are underway
as the chesapeake bay the estuary that
big spring run feeds into
grapples with how to reduce incoming
nutrient and sediment loads
the contributions of legacy sediment are
still unsettled
continuing to understand how humans have
transformed landscapes will be vital to
ensuring that the money
and time invested in re-sculpting rivers
is ultimately helping not harming the
environment